I came up in the Chicago comedy scene
and my first sort of job promotional guy
for old-style light an old-style you
should know is a very famous beer in
Chicago and they were coming out with a
new product old-style light so what they
they hired me to do was to go around a
bar three bars a night with two models
dressed in schoolgirl outfits and
t-shirts and koozies like sort of old
style light swag okay I'm in right drive
to pay you to be involved his right said
and they they said now they actually
they paid me you know I was so excited
about this job and after the first night
it was clear that this was a terrible
situation
I threw t-shirts to people and they
threw them back at me and so then the
models it all fit we got another model
she quit literally on the third day so
then they said well that you just have
to do it on your own and I said okay cuz
I really needed money the first time the
old-style clients came to see me do this
live and in action it was at a dive bar
so the only thing I have that is really
separating me from the patrons of the
bar and being a comedian was the
microphone from the speaker and that
failed and I said well you know
to his performance the ad agency was
like we have to gotta do something and
so what do you want me to do and I said
just stand on a stool and yell and
that's what I did and they could not
forget how terrible my routine was as I
stood on a stool and yelled at people
going
who likes old-style light huh come on
free t-shirts and I literally that night
I offered everyone free beers and they
were so upset that I was so unfunny that
they didn't even accept them so I drank
to $50 tab myself and I sheepishly left
with the stool at the end of that run I
they asked to do another run because it
had been so successful but it's
mortified and embarrassed publicly in
almost all the bars in Chicago now I
said you'd have to pay me twice as much
as you're already paying me for me to
ever consider and they went okay and I I
didn't know what to do I should have
asked for like five hundred dollars a
night but I so I had to do it